un chef infatigable non bâti une brigade
de bénévoles très motivés
combien de sa nature faire les quatre
cents places une usine à saint louis en
fait sur son core v santé exécutif on
étale ça va vite on rappe depuis deux
semaines le restaurant du chef charles
antoine crête s'est transformé en
cuisine externe de l'accueil bonneau
chaque jour l'organisme dépose les
denrées alimentaires dont il dispose
le chef et son équipe font le reste pour
nous mais de produire 1500 2000 sandwich
par jour sans nous prendre nous prend la
dixième du temps ça va prendre
labeouf a réservé à l'accueil bonneau
cette mobilisation les bénévoles la juge
nécessaire ceux qui ont les moyens
possibilité d'aider ce que présentement
c'est du bon temps d'investir des ronces
apprentissage l'an dernier on est quand
même privilégié pour la majorité d'entre
nous si on peut pas oublier qu'il ya des
gens qui sont encore plus dans le besoin
de crise comme ça les sandwichs du chef
charles antoine crette de son armée de
bénévoles se retrouvent dans ces sacs à
l'accueil bonneau
ici aussi tout le monde est à l'oeuvre
on essaie de travailler d'un plaisir
mais de l'amour dans nos loges pour
penser à nos gars qui ont rien chaque
jour ce sont plus de 600 personnes en
situation d'itinérance qui en profite
un gros merci à ben je des fois même
plus d'amour dans la personne à leur
service à les écouter que la pop
personnes
ici à ce mitraillage radio canada
montréal